y a pas autre chose
c'est nul ça c'est parce que tu connais
pas l'histoire ou manon vincent su avec
la gourmette avait rompu avec rebecca
pas s'ils croyaient à tort que c'était
une balance alors que celle existant de
la croix-de-chavaux qui avait informé
hier mandel lequel à la suite du casse
de la bijouterie raspail s'était servie
de vincent théval comme dan indique pour
assurer sa protection
vincent est revenu du brésil où il avait
ouvert un bar à cocktails et airs propre
rebecca rebecca c'est celle qui va
poteau elle était d'arrêter de fumer en
a bavé brion mais ils vont faire là bas
c'est normal ils sont contents de se
retrouver
c'est pas qu'on change non si je rappe
ne serait ce que 5 minutes après je me
perds dans les intrigues moment je
cherche un dessert